the biden administration downplays the
evil of the communist cuban regime while
simultaneously labeling american
conservatives
authoritarian racist i'm ben shapiro
this is the bench bureau show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
protect your data from bigtech with the
vpn i trust visit expressvpn.com
ben well the biden administration had a
choice when faced with the fact that
there's this massive movement in cuba
against
the regime the bad administration could
have taken the obama attack or they
could have taken the more traditional
democratic attack so
you'll recall that the democratic party
was not pro-cuba for the vast majority
of cuba's communist existence it was jfk
who was
the leading sponsor of attempts to
overthrow the castro regime
in cuba and democrats after that were
not big fans of the
castro regime or the communism that it
was pushing
and yet now the democratic party seems
split and this is reflected in the
attitude of the
biden white house toward the current
cuban dissident movement
what we are watching in cuba right now
is perfectly predictable we are watching
as the as the cuban regime cracks down
on dissidents
there's a disney a dissident named luis
emmanuel alcantara
who i spoke with just a few weeks ago
via phone
he was in cuba the cuban security
services cut off the call he talked
about the movement
he explained what the movement was it
was not based merely on
economic circumstances in cuba it was
not based merely on the lack of vaccines
in cuba
it was not based in other words on
things that had arisen in the last five
minutes
it was in fact a movement that was
rooted in a lack of liberty it was a
movement
rooted in opposition to the communist
regime itself
and its unwillingness to allow for basic
human freedoms in the state
well now luis manuel alcantra has been
detained by the castor regime
his family and friends have no idea
where he is and this is happening to
dissidents
all over the island as is perfectly
predictable because as it turns out
communist regimes authoritarian regimes
the way they treat dissidents
is by picking them up and tossing them
in dang cells and leaving them there
for as long as humanly possible or
outright killing them those are usually
the chief available and useful options
to these regimes
and so this does raise the question what
should the united states position be
now on a moral level the united states
position should be pretty obvious
right it should be the position of
traditional democrats which is that the
cuban regime ought to be condemned and
we have to do everything in our powers
to see that regime topple
and then there is the obama position the
obama position was that the u.s embargo
on cuba
had created the conditions that allowed
for the continuation of the regime
so obama's viewing foreign policy was
always that the united states was at
fault and the way for the united states
to
allow other regimes to change is to be
warm to them be cuddly to them be
friendly to them
this is why he suggested that the way to
open up iran's
authoritarian dictatorship was to pass
them
into the economy of the world make them
part of the family of nations
it didn't work iran continued to fund
terrorism all over the region
and then obama tried the same thing with
cuba he suggested that if we just opened
up cuba's economy if he got rid of the
travel embargo if we got rid of many of
the sanctions this would somehow
make cuba thrive cuba would become a
better place to live
and the regime would be less stable of
course precisely the opposite happened
the cuban regime became slightly more
stable because when you give dictators
more money it turns out they use that
money
in order to solidify their rule over the
areas in which they
have total control okay so this has led
to a bit of a conflict inside the biden
white house there are a bunch of old
obama holdovers who seem to continue to
have the perspective that the united
states is the problem
in cuba and that the cuban regime ought
to be treated with a certain level of
respect
with kid gloves and then there's some
old school democrats
who including joe biden by the way who
seem to be
less sanguine about the cuban regime and
this is evident
from the sort of statements that are
being made by the biden administration
which are in conflict
with themselves right they are not
internally consistent
so joe biden did put out a statement
here was joe biden's statement he said
we stand with the cuban people and their
clarion call for freedom and relief from
the tragic grip of the pandemic
and from the decades of repression and
economic suffering to which they have
been subjected
by cuba's authoritarian regime the cuban
people are bravely asserting fundamental
and universal rights
those rights including the right of
peaceful protest and the right to freely
determine their own future
must be respected okay so far that
statement is not bad
right so far he's calling the regime
authoritarian
he's talking about its repression and
his economic suffering due to the regime
he's talking about the universal rights
of the cuban people and then he gets to
the final sentence
the united states calls on the cuban
regime to hear their people and serve
their needs at this vital moment
rather than enriching themselves now
that is not a call for the cuban regime
to respect the human rights of its
people
that is not a call for the cuban regime
to respect the individual ability
of cubans to descend from the evils of
the regime
to use those supposedly universal rights
like the right of peaceful protest and
the right to freely determine their own
future
and cuba has been subverting those
rights for six decades at this point for
62 years since the 1959 cuban revolution
the last sentence where the united
states calls on cuba
not to allow for free speech not to
allow for freedom of assembly but to
take care of the problem
that is obama speak okay the obama speak
there is well if the cuban regime
would just give its people a little bit
more medicine if the cuban regime would
just take care of the
social welfare of its people well then
the communist regime could stay and the
human rights are completely secondary
this is a perverse view of the cuban
regime and it's a perverse view
of what exactly is going on in the first
place because the reality once again
is that the cuban regime is
the problem it is not that the current
problems in cuba
are a result of any sort of extraneous
force they are not
okay they are they are the deepest
effect of the underlying problems
it's so funny the left in the united
states will suggest that everything that
happens in the united states is the
result of underlying structural racism
and this is their big shtick but when it
comes to cuba the left in the united
states wants to separate off
the current economic circumstances the
current inability to pass out vaccines
from supposedly this
incredible national health care system
they they don't want to attribute any of
that to the obvious underlying
structural problem which is not
something vague
like structural racism that has been
alleviated in the united states over the
course of the past six decades
no this is absolutely clear this is a
country that has repressed the ability
of its own citizens to hold private
property
the way that you go to the supermarket
in cuba is the the government hands
you this the script that you can only
use at the supermarket
and then they give you the products at
prices that cuba's regime
thinks you ought to pay it is an unfree
society which is again
why tens of thousands of human beings
have attempted to float their way
from an island 90 miles off the coast of
florida through shark-infested
waters all the way to places like miami
and just one second we'll get to the
continued conflict inside the biden
regime because
once again there's this internal
division in ten biden's own mind i think
between the old biden who was the
quote-unquote moderate biden and the new
biden who is woke
and bernie sanders-esque on all this by
the way we are
now talking about 72 hours of this going
on without any comment from bernie
sanders who's busily
tweeting about the evils of jeff bezos
from his lake house
it's uh it's very convenient to be a
communist in the united states it's not
nearly as convenient to be a communist
subject
of authoritarian regimes in cuba or hong
kong for example
we'll get to more in a second first let
us talk about the fact that you are
dependent on coffee i am dependent on
coffee i will tell you the truth i was
not a huge coffee drinker until like the
last two three years now my kids get me
up
at every available hour and this means i
need my coffee and i want coffee that
tastes great from a company that isn't
going to spit in my eye over my politics
and that is why i
enjoy black rifle coffee black rifle
coffee company is a veteran-owned coffee
company serving premium coffee
to people who love america veteran ceo
and founder evan hafer spent over seven
years on the ground overseas with u.s
special forces
and as a cia contractor black rifle is
continually committed to supporting
veteran law enforcement and first
responder causes and this summer
black rifle invites you to enjoy your
coffee by that they don't just mean the
great taste of america's coffee but more
about the places you drink it the
passion and adventure it fuels and
inspires the entertainment black rifle
serves
along the way whether you're brewing the
perfect cup of pour over before kicking
tail at work or
heading out on your next back country
mission black rifle is here to fuel your
way wherever the summer
takes you they import high quality
coffee beans from all over the world
they roast five days a week of their
facilities in tennessee and salt lake
city utah the team at brc
is continually researching and
experimenting with new roasting methods
and coffee origins they are spectacular
honestly i rely on their coffee
fuel your summer with america's coffee
black rifle coffee go to
blackriflecoffee.com to get 20
off your purchase and your first coffee
club order that is blackriflecoffee.com
shapiro so part of what what drives
the the sort of obama-esque view of how
cuba ought to be treated as a
particular view of the united states and
its values there's a view that obama
made mainstream on the left
and it had been mainstream back in the
70s but kind of fell out of favor with
the rise of the reagan era which was
that america was inherently bad
america's involvement in vietnam was bad
america's involvement in iraq was bad
and america's involvement in cuba is bad
america is the nefarious force in the
world
and the real problems that americans
need to face down are the problems here
at home
america doesn't have anything to say
about what happens in the rest of the
world because after all america is just
too perverse america is just too
wrong-headed
america is just too much of a problem so
this has led as i say
to this conflict inside the biden
administration on the one hand you have
joe biden
who is speaking sort of classical
democrat language from the jfk days
talking about how the people of the
united states stand firmly with the
people of cuba here was
the president of the united states
saying the right thing with regard to
cuba yesterday
cuba people demanding their freedom
from an authoritarian regime and i don't
think we've seen anything
like this protest uh in
a long long time if quite frankly ever
the united states stands firmly with the
people of cuba
as they assert their universal rights
and they call on the government
government cuba to refrain from violence
their attempts to silence the voice of
the people of cuba okay this is the
right statement right credit where
credit is due joe biden is saying the
right thing the problem
is his administration immediately
started trying to walk a lot of this
stuff back so first they said that the
statement that he put out
was written for him right not by him for
him
then jon saki tried to downplay what was
happening in cuba
as merely a sort of spontaneous eruption
at the lack of economic opportunity and
the problems with regard to vaccine
distribution in cuba this is not
true it is not true i've been talking to
cuban dissidents for the last several
weeks
they were planning this sort of stuff
for weeks on end there was a burgeoning
democratic movement in cuba i knew weeks
ago that people were going to get out in
the streets people in cuba knew weeks
ago that they were going to get out into
the streets this is not just about the
way the cuban regime is handling its
problems right now and this again
is a sort of pattern in the way the
democrats view the world when a bad
thing happens out there they like to say
not that it's a pattern that springs
from the nefarious evil of underlying
institutions
right when it was benghazi it wasn't the
nefarious evil of isis that was to blame
or america's soft stance with regard to
security in places like libya that was
to blame
no it was just a spontaneous eruption of
upset
over a random youtube video and now
according to gen saki what's going on in
cuba is a spontaneous eruption
thanks to economic dislocation that is
untrue it is not
true the cuban people do not wish to
live under the
boot heel of this regime any longer and
downplaying what is happening in cuba as
some sort of like
spontaneous reaction to current economic
circumstance ignores the fact that a
huge percentage
of south florida's population are cuban
expatriates who fled from the country
specifically because it is an oppressive
hell hole
okay here's jinsaki sort of downplaying
the cause that people are fighting and
now being imprisoned and probably dying
for in cuba
there's every indication that
yesterday's protests were
spontaneous expressions of people who
are exhausted with the cuban
government's economic mismanagement
and repression and those these are
protests inspired by the harsh reality
of everyday life
in cuba not people uh in another country
i'm saying that because i think there
have been a range of accusations out
there as you
well know okay and then she says well
you know it was really the lack of
vaccines
that caused all of this trying to
downplay this as lack of vaccines
or spontaneous eruptions over the
economy ignores the fact there have been
people
on the ground planning this sort of
stuff for decades fighting this sort of
stuff for decades not just in cuba but
also outside of cuba
we've talked to them on the program
here's shinsaki again taking the sort of
obama-esque approach here
obviously one of the issues that uh the
uh that protesters are
justifiably out there in the streets uh
protesting about
is hunger is lack of access to vaccines
etc but we are continuing to provide a
range of assistance which we will
continue to do
okay now here's the problem one of the
big problems is not just the moral
problem
with sort of making light of the
underlying evil of the cuban regime
the bigger problem is that the solution
that would seem to be called for by
diagnosis of the problem as just
coveted vaccines or lack of economic
opportunity is you ship some money in
some vaccines over there
i just throw them some cash throw them
them throw them some vaccines and then
call it a day
that would seem to be the dictated
solution that of course is not a
solution
the solution is the fault of the regime
the united states
can't necessarily effectuate that from
the outside but we certainly can do a
whole hell of a lot more
than simply talk about how you know they
may botch this one
peter ducey from fox news was back in
the white house press room and uh asking
the tough questions so he said um yeah
so you guys keep saying it's about
vaccines in the economy i've noticed
that they are not shouting vaccines
and the economy they are shouting
freedom and enough here's peter juicy
grilling gensake when these protesters
are yelling
freedom and enough there are people
within the administration who think
they're
saying freedom from rising covert cases
again i would say that when people are
out there in the streets protesting and
complaining about the lack of access
to economic prosperity
to the medical supplies they need to a
life they deserve to live
that can take on a range of meetings
there's a global pandemic right now
most people in that country don't have
access to vaccines that certainly is
something we'd love to help with it
could take on a range of meanings
well no they're being very very they're
marching with the american flag
and this is the point and this is where
it gets very uncomfortable
for jen saki and the biden
administration again they're of divided
mind on the one hand
joe biden wants to say that he's a
patriot who loves the american flag
on the other hand joe biden refuses to
say to his left flank that they are
doing something wrong
in burning the american flag or stomping
on the american flag or kneeling for the
american flag and this makes for a very
uncomfortable situation for them when
cuba breaks out like this
because when people of cuba are flying
the american flag and saying we want our
freedom
and people on joe biden's left are
saying america shouldn't get involved
because america is the problem america
is bad the true authoritarian threat
is not from actual authoritarians the
true authoritarian threat is here at
home
it puts joe biden in the middle of a
vice he's not willing to stand up to his
left and he's not willing to stand up
for his own principles
here was jen saki having a tough time
explaining why dissenters in cuba are
even flying the american flag now for
any normal person
any normal american this is a very easy
answer the reason that cuban dissenters
cuban patriots are flying the american
flag and not just the cuban flag
is because america stands for liberty
because the declaration of independence
promulgates principles that are
universal in nature because the united
states has been a beacon of hope for
oppressed people around the world
for centuries at this point that is a
very simple answer
and and yes it is wrong for americans to
disdain their own flag there's something
deeply ungrateful and wrong with it yes
they have a right to do it but you've
already do lots of stuff in america
that's incredibly dumb and wrong-headed
you have a right in the united states of
america to write more on on your own
forehead that would be a that'd be a
stupid thing to do
just because you have a right to do
something doesn't mean you ought to do
it or that you are right to do it
but the bite administration does not
have the stones to simply tell its own
left you guys are wrong on this sort of
stuff so
this leads to the uncomfortable
realization that gensake
can't even just acknowledge the
realities which is that the cuban
descenders are right and a lot of
americans are wrong
does the administration support
international protesters flying the
american flag
and what message do you have to
americans who are wary of flying it here
in the u.s well i would say first
the the president certainly values and
respects uh
the uh the uh symbol of
the american flag he's someone who
certainly uh
waves it outside of his uh house or does
in delaware and
and other places where he's lived
throughout his time uh but he also
believes that people have the right to
peaceful protests and he thinks both can
be true
well both are true of right to peaceful
protest and also the people
who are protesting by disdaining the
american flag are morons
they're world historical idiots both of
those things can be true but you won't
say that she won't say that
instead she'll downplay the cuban
protest as sort of a situational
problem she will ignore the fact that it
is idiotic to protest
the beacon that is the united states and
by the way the more that the united
states refuses to stand up for itself
as a beacon of freedom the less that
american flag actually means to people
around the world you want to see the
center stop flying the american flag
please keep promulgating policy
like this in just one second we'll get
to the folks that democrats are really
threatened by the folks that they really
are worried about
it's not cuban authoritarians it is not
the chinese regime that just stomped all
over hong kong it's not the iranian
terrorists who run the country
no they're worried about you really are
worried about you anybody who is
conservative anybody who's center
right anybody who's center all of you
people are the people who they are
worried about you're the true
authoritarian threat
we'll get to more of that in just one
second first let us talk for a second
about the
greatest underwear in the world so i'm
talking about tommy john underwear they
just
are the best they graze this magnificent
tucas every single day
apollo men's underwear is proven to keep
you drier and up to seven degrees cooler
than regular cotton underwear that's why
tommy john doesn't have customers they
have fanatics i am a fanatic about tommy
john by the way i took literally all of
my other pairs of underwear and i threw
them in the garbage
apollo underwear is soft supportive
stretches for the perfect fit every day
is available
up to size 4xl with over 15 million
pairs old men across america love
tommy john underwear because there's no
more discomfort no more chafing and like
all tommy john underwear apollo comes
with the best pair you'll ever wear or
it's free guarantee
tommy john's new apollo men's underwear
is high end you can't get them anywhere
else
right now get twenty percent off your
first order at tommyjohn.com
ben go to tommyjohns.com for 20 percent
off tommyjohn.com see site for details
by the way they have stuff for ladies as
well
my wife loves tommy john products tommy
john just makes comfortable stuff it
fits
great it's incredibly durable it goes
washed 29 times feels the same
as when it came out of the package it's
just great tommyjohn.com
for 20 off today okay so while the bite
administration seems of at best split
mind over how to handle
the problems in cuba and again joe biden
gets personal credit
or being mostly right but then his
administration as so often happens
tends to walk this stuff back meanwhile
the language with regard
to the to the supposed voting crackdown
by republicans is far harsher from
democrats than anything they have to say
about the cuban authoritarian regime
you got a regime 90 miles off the coast
of the united states
that is currently taking dissidents and
throwing them in prison and or shooting
them
and the language democrats use with
regards to that particular regime is
significantly nicer
significantly more measured than the
kind of language that this white house
uses with regard to people who disagree
on voter id
for example shinsaki i mean there's a
certain
there's got to be an irony here so the
fact that the administration
calls uses the same exact term to refer
to a cuban regime that has not held an
honest vote in 62 years
and texas legislators who want voter id
it's it's an astonishing thing it really
is
here's jen saki yesterday saying that
voter suppression laws
being pushed right now suppression law
they're not suppression laws okay
there's yet to be any evidence that he
suppressed the vote in any meaningful
way
or even designed to suppress the vote
but jen saki says we are now watching
voter suppression laws so authoritarian
that they are the worst threat to
democracy since the civil war
now i can think of a few threats to
i can think there's a hundred years of
jim crow that's pretty big threat to
democracy
it turns out you know actual overt laws
designed to stop black people from
voting in the south that seems like a
threat to democracy
it seems like a threat to democracy
under these terms that women couldn't
vote
until there was an actual amendment to
the constitution
in the 1910s right see i mean we're
talking since the civil war you know it
seems like an awful threat to the to the
democracy
woodrow wilson's willingness to imprison
dissidents or fdr's crackdown on a
federal level
when people wouldn't fly the blue eagle
or for that matter
the nazi attempts to destroy the united
states during world war ii
or for that matter the 1960s attempts to
wreck america's institutions from within
like all of these seem
like pretty significant threats to
democracy you don't have threats to
democracy
how about the fact that we had riots in
major cities across the united
and states it seems like kind of a
threat to democracy that the
intelligence apparatus was activated
against a presidential campaign last
time around but according to gensake
what we are watching right now
is an authoritarian threat from
republicans remember they are using the
exact
same words to describe the cuban regime
that they're using to describe
republicans
that's unreal it's unreal okay using the
exact same terminology to describe
the in fact they're nicer about the
cuban regime after all the people who
are protesting the cuban regime
they're really just fighting you know
economic discontent and vaccine
shortages
really i mean like do we really know
what they're fighting for but we
perfectly well know
why people are angry at republicans and
it's because they're an authoritarian
threat to the united states
worse than any threat since an attempt
by an
armed band of rebels to break away from
the country
in 1860 that's a hell of a contention
we'll get some more of that in just
one second first let us talk about how
you make your company better if your
business is growing zipper crew
is the way to go right now you can try
it for free
at zip recruiter dot com slash daily
wire zip recruiter doesn't wait for
great candidates to find you
zip recruiter finds them for you when
you post a job on zip recruiter get sent
out to over 100 top job sites with just
one click to increase your chances of
reaching top talent
then ziprecruiter's powerful matching
technology scans thousands of resumes to
find people with the right skills and
experience for your job
and actively invites them to apply to
get qualified candidates fast no wonder
four out of five employers who post
unzip recruiter get a quality candidate
within the very first day let's say for
example that you're looking
for somebody who really knows security
like an excellent security person to
handle
your security and company security but
also you you have another
specific recommendation you need
something you need a stand-up comedian
you need a security guy and also a
stand-up comedian
well zip recruiter helps you come up
with somebody like chad start finding
great candidates today when you try zip
recruiter for free just go to this
exclusive
web address zippercrew.com dailywire
that is ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e-zip ziprecruiter.com
slash daily wire zip recruit remains
the smartest way to hire alrighty so
jen saki literally said yesterday
on the same day that cuban dissidents
were in the streets attempting to
overthrow a natural authoritarian regime
she used that word not to describe the
authoritarian regime so much of cuba
but to describe republicans who want to
do things like
make you apply for an absentee ballot
kind of the same as you know rigging an
election for 62 years feels the same
or or they want you to use voter id or
they're getting rid
of wait for it drive by balloting feels
exactly the same
as you know shooting people in the
streets over in havana here is jen
sackey using the same word
he'll also decry efforts to strip the
right to vote as authoritarian and
anti-american
as a and stand up against the notion
that politicians should be allowed to
choose
their voters or to subvert our system by
replacing independent election
authorities with partisan ones
and he will highlight the work of the
administration against this the
necessity of passing the for the people
act and the john lewis voting rights
advancement act
and how we need to work together with
civil rights organizations
to build as broad a turnout in voter
education system to overcome
the worst challenge to our democracy
since the civil the worst challenge for
our democracy since the civil war
are you out of your damn mind by the way
if you're talking about the
authoritarian threats of the country
right now the culturally authoritarian
threats of the country that is coming
from institutions
that will un-person you if you happen to
cross their preferred politics
that is the democratic party that is
hoping to seize control of the voting
apparatuses of all 50 states and bring
them up to the federal level so they can
then skew elections through things like
mandate mandatory ballot harvesting if
you want to talk about like
actual authoritarian threats it is not
coming from states that have their own
voting laws many of which are more
liberal than blue states
but the the unbelievable
contrast between the language that the
democrats use with regard to cuba
and the language they use with regard to
republicans it is an astonishing thing
and it also allows democrats to be just
as undemocratic as they want to be
the same people who are saying it's an
authoritarian threat to our democracy to
call for voter id say it is not an
authoritarian threat to our democracy
for the entire texas democratic
delegation to literally abscond from the
state
so this is what happened yesterday in
texas according to the new york times
quote
texas democrats fled the state on monday
in a last-ditch effort to prevent the
passage of a restrictive new voting law
by the republican-controlled legislature
heading to washington to draw national
attention to their cause nothing by the
way is going to
speak to the common texan quite like
texas democrats absconding to washington
dc the center of all federal power
to suggest that they are being put upon
by the way in a private jet
unmasked i should note these are real
representatives of the people
they're the kind of these are these are
dirt under the fingernails
gritty hard-working lawyers who take
private jets to washington dc while
talking about how courageous they are
the group left austin in mid-afternoon
on a pair of chartered flights that were
scheduled to arrive by early evening
an official involved with the efforts
said more than 51 of the 67 state house
democrats had signed on enough to
prevent texas
texas republicans from obtaining a
quorum which is required to conduct
state business
the hastily arranged departure added a
cinematic element to the partisan
wrangling in a state with a colorful
political history i love how the new
york times treats this
like oh well isn't this just colorful
fun isn't this wonderful just like they
treated it
as colorful fun when the wisconsin state
legislature
just a few years back in the middle of
some anti-union and
and free labor bills was invaded by a
bunch of union members and taken over
with wisconsin capital and when a bunch
of wisconsin democrats fled to illinois
in order to deny a quorum whenever
democrats do this sort of stuff it's not
undemocratic so just to get this
straight the filibuster
is undemocratic because republicans
won't give democrats enough votes
to kill the filibuster but it is not
only democratic
it is colorful fun when democrats who
don't have a majority let alone
they certainly don't have a super
majority they don't have enough to deny
republicans the ability to do their
business
instead they literally pick up and leave
the state to deny a quorum okay that is
you want to talk about thwarting the
democratic process it seems like you
know not going to the legislature
just to deny the quorum that's probably
not something
that was originally intended by the
people who wanted there to be a quorum
was what if an entire party just decides
they're not going to go to work that day
and they call out sick
by the way the reason they're fleeing
the state is because they can be
compelled to show up at the texas state
legislature you can actually send the
cops
to go and bring them so you have a
quorum they can actually do that
in most states the hastily arranged
departure says the new york times added
a cinematic element to the partisan
wrangling in a state with a colorful
political history
democrats have fled to neighboring
states in the past to try to block
legislation including in 2003
when they traveled to new mexico and
oklahoma in an effort to avoid
republican attempts to redraw
congressional districts
the move could paralyze the legislature
for weeks if democrats remain out of the
state until the special session ends in
august
still it lays bare their limited options
long term in the legislature where the
republicans hold the majority in both
chambers
parliamentary procedures and efforts to
add amendments can delay the process but
not to rail it
republicans said on monday the democrats
gambit would ultimately fail state
representative briscoe kane
a houston area republican who chairs the
house elections committee said the
democrats departure quote slows things
down
but would not prevent republicans from
prevailing it's just denying the
inevitable
mr kane said describing the move as
political theater will eventually get it
done
one way or another nevertheless
by traveling on mass to washington the
texas democrats were hoping to apply
pressure to democrats
in the u.s senate who so far been able
to have been unable to pass federal
legislation to address the issue
so we now have the specter of texas
democrats
leaving the state where they have a
legal duty to show up showing up in
washington dc
and asking senate democrats to kill the
filibuster in order to pass federalizing
legislation that violates the
constitution of the united states but
don't worry it's the texas republicans
who are an authoritarian threat worse
than anything we've seen since the civil
war
fairly incredible now i know you may be
asking yourself what exactly is in this
awful awful
texas republican bill like what's so bad
about this texas voting bill
i will tell you nothing the latest bill
in texas according to npr
not a warm toward republican source
includes new ig requirements for people
voting by mail
and also local election officials are
not allowed to send vote-by-mail
applications to people who haven't
requested one
why well because very often you are
sending vote-by-mail applications
to people who no longer live at those
addresses we moved to florida
apparently one of these things showed up
in our mailbox in california because
they have these sorts of stupid rules in
california
also texas was going to ban drive
through voting and extending hours
during early voting
republicans of the state say that these
innovations opened the door to voter
fraud
again these were mostly procedures that
were put in place temporarily thanks to
the pandemic
and then democrats said it's the new
normal just like everything else in
government
once you the ratchet only works one way
once you ratchet in these
emergency options then they become the
de facto new normal and once you push
back on them then democrats claim that
you are undermining the system that was
implemented
like 37 seconds ago thanks to you know a
global pandemic
i will say the funniest specter in all
of this is democrats declaring
themselves heroes for all this
this is really funny so there's a guy
named james talarico
he's a texas state representative and
here is what
he tweeted he's a democrat quote
just landed in memphis on our way to dc
thank you all for your well wishes
we left behind our families our
livelihoods
and our beloved texas but our sacrifice
is nothing
compared to the sacrifices brave
americans have made throughout history
to protect the sacred right to vote
ah the heartbreaking beauty okay so here
is the thing um
your sacrifice you say that your
sacrifice is nothing compared to
sacrifice no
your sacrifice is nothing the the
sentence should have ended after the
word nothing
you're not sacrificing anything you got
in a private jet you went to washington
dc you're going to stay at a five-star
hotel you're gonna have whiskey with a
bunch of democratic colleagues the media
are going to treat you
as though you're a wonderful hero and
then you'll go back to texas and nothing
will change so really
slow clap golf clap for all of y'all
real real really impressive stuff
we left behind our families you're not
fleeing from cuba gang
you know how i know because if you were
fleeing from cuba democrats would
probably oppose you
my oh my god the these sort of pathetic
self-indulgent nonsense of our politics
it's so
yeah it's so just gross fighting
authoritarianism in texas because of
voter id
so folks like me when i say that the
left is engaged in authoritarianism
my purported my proposed solution is
more liberty
right it's leave me the hell alone
generally leave people alone
when the left suggests that they are in
against authoritarianism
their rule is we need more top down
control
which means they're really not
anti-authoritarian they're just kind of
anti
their political opponents there's a
reason i wrote i have a brand new book
it's coming out called the authoritarian
moment
it comes out july 27th you should go
pre-order it right now because it is all
about this it's about the militarization
weaponization of every institution in
major american society
and how we can reverse that course
but again the left is so fond of
declaring things authoritarian unless
they're actually authoritarian
apparently
it's it's very very troubling speaking
of authoritarianism we'll get some
cultural authoritarianism
on the trans issue in just one second
first let us talk
about a simple fact there are a thousand
reasons why protecting your home matters
to you
i know it matters to me three of those
reasons are my kids
i gotta make sure i know what's going on
in my property so i know where my kids
are at all times i mean frankly they
just run around all the time i can't
keep track of all of them and then i
pop up the ring device on my phone and
now i know what is going on so get ring
alarm for yourself go to ring.com slash
ben it is the perfect way to start your
ring experience
besides ring being a powerful asset for
my home ring is also an affordable whole
home security system you can easily
install yourself
it's never been more important to be
able to see who's there or what's
happening anytime around the house
inside or outside
and i can see it all in one simple app
that's right with ring my family and i
can keep an eye on our home no matter
where we are right from our phone
it's great to know you'll never miss a
visitor with rings hassle-free easy to
install indoor and outdoor cams
and know when those packages are
delivered start protecting your home
today with ring alarm go to ring.com
to get your ring alarm security kit
today you can build the system that is
right for your home have it up and
running in just minutes that is ring.com
slash ben once more ring dot com slash
ben go check them out right now
but ring.com get your ring alarm
security kit today okay we will get to
the authoritarianism the cultural
authoritarianism of the trans movement
in just one second because
it is growing first again a reminder
whether we're talking totalitarian
lockdown measures that destroyed the
middle class
while telling you that it was wonderful
to go out and protest for george floyd
or
whether we were talking about the
indoctrination of school children
the attempts by hollywood to cram down a
particular point of view and fire
everyone who disagrees
the freedom of everyday americans is
under assault you can feel it you talk
to conservatives
even moderates across the spectrum they
feel like they are being silenced
because
they are this is the reason i wrote the
authoritarian moment tell people like
you learn as much about how we got here
and how you can fight back
as you possibly can the big thing here
is how to fight back
there are a couple of different types of
authoritarianism there's governmental
authoritarianism like you see in cuba
and then there is the social
authoritarianism that suggests
you must be excised from polite society
for disagreeing
and the weaponization of institutions on
behalf of that perverse notion
this is why you need the authoritarian
moment my new book is available for
pre-order at amazon barnes noble or any
other
major bookseller you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
now speaking of cultural
authoritarianism there is a
a fascinating piece that has been being
presented now by the journal of medical
ethics
the june 2021 issue declaring
that lgbt children
should be allowed to get whatever
treatment they seek we're talking about
minors
without parental veto power and the
reason for this of course
is because we have declared that parents
are an obstacle to the new utopia
we have declared that you are wrong and
immoral and bad
if you so much as stand up for science
if you so much to stand up for the
notion
that male and female are categories that
exist then you are the bad one
and there is a reason why the aclu is
declaring people authoritarian for
suggesting
that boys and girls play in separate
leagues there's a reason why
jen saki is doing the same thing there's
a reason why texas democrats are
declaring texas republicans
authoritarian
for making the suggestion that
biological men should not compete with
biological women
in college sports and the reason is
because they have a totalitarian view
of right and wrong and a totalitarian
view that is completely contrary to
science
so you're announcing i'm proud i promise
you within five years
there will be active measures taken in
states like california to remove
children from homes
where children have exhibited any level
of gender confusion and parents refuse
to go along with the program
it's already happening in places like
seattle so you're gonna see it happen in
california and more broadly
across america that's authoritarianism
you call cps on somebody because
little bobby shows up to school and says
that he's janus
and instead of the teacher setting him
straight or allowing parents to set him
straight the teachers immediately
start mainlining him into the entire
gender industry and telling parents they
have no right to parent their own
children
that that is the next move it's going to
lead some pretty wild side effects
and and again it's this is the
mainstreaming of delusion obviously
you want to see mainstreaming of
delusion there is apparently
a series that uh is is called nine
months with courtney cox
it's a docu-series about various couples
having children
and this went viral yesterday it is a
video
from apparently season three episode
eight
of nine months with courtney cox and it
features
a transgender man meaning a biological
woman
who pushed is a biological woman who had
a baby there's not a man who had a baby
because that's not possible it's a
biological woman
who used her uterus to create a baby and
then push the baby out through her
vagina because she's a biological woman
once more
and no amount of testosterone that
produces facial hair or growing the hair
out
or mastectomies changes the fact that
this is a biological woman as evidenced
by the fact that biological men
cannot give birth biology i promise you
babies can't fit through the urethra i
think a kidney stone is bad try fitting
a watermelon through there in any case
this particular episode of this bizarre
show features
a transgender man meaning a biological
woman
who is married to a transgender woman
meaning a biological man so
this means a man who is married to a
woman but they believe they are members
of the opposite gender
so in this particular scenario the
quote-unquote husband the faux husband
meaning a biological woman gave birth
and the faux woman meaning a biological
man
is the quote-unquote mother in this
scenario and this leads to the bizarre
situation
that apparently the parents have now
refused to accept
id for their newborn baby because that
would require
the birth mother you know like the
actual woman to identify
as a mother and not the male
okay by the way you're a bigot if you
disagree
not only are you bigot if you bring up
your children to disagree the left will
will sick
the authoritarian regime on you i mean
this is the way this is going to go over
the next few years
you watch and here is uh the bizarre new
world we have created for ourselves the
counter-reality new world we have
created for ourselves
not only are we not assigning a sex to
the baby dc is forcing me to
label myself as the mother and that's
not the case but throne is the mother
this whole birth certificate thing is is
really
it's really causing me a lot
trans women can be mothers oh i have to
put it over here
okay this is perfect pause for a second
to understand what just happened
okay if you're not watching this the
video then cuts to
the the quote-unquote mother a
biological male
attempting to feed a human child with
his chest
now this is not going to work because it
turns out that biological males do not
have
milk ducts so it's going to be rather
difficult for the baby to
get any sort of nutrition from all of
this of course
but it doesn't matter so long as these
people feel better about themselves sure
the baby's gonna starve to death
but at least the delusional parents feel
better about themselves
and this is being championed these are
civil rights heroes civil rights heroes
is a man
who is sticking his nipple in the mouth
of a child in the mouth of a small baby
in a bizarre attempt to nourish the baby
with literally nothing
and you're a bigot if you disagree don't
you see don't worry is it
you're the authoritarian for suggesting
there is a problem here
or that perhaps it is not in the best
interest of a child to grow up
under these circumstances that's all for
in fact if you suggest that maybe the
cps should come for your kids
if you suggest that sort of thing and we
can continue with this
[Music]
does anyone give a damn about the kid
apparently not it's a kids are just a
purse they're just a tool for people to
use for their own personal enjoyment
apparently
the baby has been able to latch but
i've not been able to produce any milk
cause you're a dude because
we're going to supplement the feeding
with formula so that
my baby is still getting the the
nutrients that they need
but i'm still feeling hopeful you're not
supplementing that's not supplementing
supplementing assumes that there is a
baseline of nutrition that is being
provided
my wife nursed all of our children and
then at a certain point because she was
working and she
didn't have time to pump you had to
supplement with formula supplementation
means not the whole thing
yeah what kind of perverse damage are
you doing to a baby you're having the
baby latch to a male nipple
and then you're like oh yeah i'm
supplementing with formula
[Music]
yeah well we've created a hell of a
society for ourselves haven't we we're a
society of science by the way
we're we are a society that is dedicated
foursquare
to science it's all we care about in
fact we are so dedicated to science
right now
like so unbelievably dedicated to
science
that apparently uh california has now
declared that all children k through 12
next year will be mandated to wear masks
in the classroom
that's how dedicated to science left is
they are so dedicated to science man
really well done everybody and if you
disagree if you disagree you should be
shut down
if you disagree then you should be
banned from social media if you disagree
the weapons of government should be used
against you if you disagree and if you
elect people who disagree
then the minority party should abscond
and deny them a quorum
all of this in the name of democracy
don't you see
and you're the authoritarian for
suggesting that objective things like
science
biology logic that these sorts of things
should apply
you are the brutal vicious authoritarian
yeah this country
you know i guess that we got so fat and
happy that we no longer had to engage in
the world of reality and that that is
really the end of it because i'll tell
you what the folks who are protesting in
cuba right now the people who are
marching in cuba at risks of their own
lives
uh i highly doubt that these sorts of
idiocies
are the things that they worry about on
a day-to-day level at a certain point
a country gets so fat and so rich and so
bored
and so stupid because the country hasn't
been challenged that we start to just
imbibe from the well of idiocy
and then we become more and more idiotic
and as we become more and more idiotic
we declare anybody who disagrees
the real threat to the country
uh yes america the the american flag
remains a beacon of liberty so long
as the uh author truly authoritarian
left loses
if the authoritarian left wins uh then
we uh have a bigger problem and so do
people
all over the world wow
things are going great guys things are
just going spectacularly well
uh one additional note uh the um
uh apparently apparently uh there's a
representative in arizona
who is also making sure that we have the
proper representation on our nation's
high courts there's another element of
the
these stupid authoritarian notions that
we're not pushing for
there is a representative greg stanton
from arizona he says that we have to
make sure that all of our courts
are represented by sexual orientation he
says it's a problem there's only one gay
member of the ninth circuit
my home state of arizona is part of the
ninth circuit
currently there is only one openly gay
member of
the bench in the ninth circuit so i want
to hear from admiral cruz and
miss diaz yeager on this one lack of
diversity in the federal judiciary
hurts our justice system how do we go
about making a plan to address such
vast disparities in making up our
federal bench
yes we definitely need to focus in as a
high priority on how many gay judges sit
on a particular judicial bench ah things
are
ah how depressing alrighty we'll be back
here later today with an additional hour
of the ben shapiro show coming up soon
the matt wall show airs at 1 30 pm
eastern be sure to check it out over at
dailywire.com
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover
production manager pavel wydowsky
associate producer bradford carrington
host producer justin barber the show is
edited by adam sciovets
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
on the matt wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events
all the fundamentals if they matter to
you come check out the show